saloperie 10
[Musique]
alors coupé c'est une comédie est une
grosse blague c'est le making-of d'un
tournage tout pourri avec des acteurs
avec des égos surdimensionnés une équipe
de techniciens pas très doué un
réalisateur complètement perdu et ça
raconte cette histoire là ce tournage et
pourquoi ça tourne mal alors les
saloperies tombes lit oui toi
oui je crois que le film coupé est aussi
une déclaration d'amour au cinéma mais
aussi une déclaration d'amour au travail
d'équipé à être solidaires tous ensemble
à faire quelque chose un objet crois que
ce soit et c'est un message très positif
et en plus de ça quand c'est une comédie
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a tous besoin
[Musique]
oui je me suis blessé je me suis tordu
la cheville mais toutes les choses
négatives qui se sont passées sur ce
tournage se sont avérées à se
transformer de manière positive donc en
me tendant la cheville je ne pouvais pas
tourner j'ai été un peu complètement
défiguré et il a plu pendant une semaine
ce qui était donc pas raccord donc on ne
pouvait pas travailler
alors en comédie shaun of the dead et on
sérieux dernier train pour bizanos et en
série de l'as kingdom
tout ce que je vois pas tout ce que
j'imagine me fait encore plus peur plus
que le l'hémoglobine et les trucs comme
ça c'est plus que tout ce qui ne bouge
une fois tout ce qui fait peur une
émotion un stress une angoisse qui vient
de quelque chose qu'on comprend pas ou
qu'on voit
tous ces liens dans une partie jeu
pourrir tout le temps que ton copain
tout est fait c'était quand même yahoo
ou 19 ans ça nous rajeunit pas du tout
comme j'ai joué dedans je n'ai pas revu
depuis au moins 16 ans donc c'est
marrant le rapport au film un peu cultes
comme ça avec des phrases cultes moi je
ne les passera par là par contre pour
vous donner une réplique culte deux noms
une réplique culte de couper saloperies
diengui je vais tout vous ouvrir
beaucoup
en délicatesse
[Musique]